I'm very excited to introduce you to Sam
bankman freed everybody likes a story
about an underdog he's the CEO of the
cryptocurrency exchange FDX the
wealthiest person under 30 in the world
someone out of the ordinary what makes
him so different and so rich he said you
always wanted to get rich but not for
the reasons you might expect an unlikely
genius who comes once in a lifetime
living with roommates sleeping on a bean
bag in his office yeah the guy's a nut
he doesn't sleep Sam is a genius and
Michael Jordan of crypto if you will
somebody who wants to change the world
for good he decided that he wanted to
dedicate his life to doing good for the
world
this is not one of those stories
in the span of about one week sand bank
and freed went from a crypto billionaire
to bankruptcy the southern district of
New York has confirmed the arrest of FTX
founder Sam bankman freed the once
crowned king of crypto now adorned in
handcuffs in the month of November 2022
one of the biggest Tales of financial
fraud was unraveling this is worse than
theranos this is worse than Madoff and
it all centered around one man and a Web
of Lies spun over the course of a few
years the devil in nerds quote is a
stunning fall from someone who is what's
considered kryptos Golden Boy many out
there who believe he's just a
pathological liar I remember watching it
unfold and wondering
how everyone seemed to believe it from
Wall Street to celebrities here's my boy
Sam from FTX and even Washington DC is
ftxt were among the top political donors
the multi-billion dollar class action
lawsuit accuses FTX its former CEO and
around a dozen celebrities of causing
some 11 billion dollars in U.S investor
losses over the last few months I wanted
to find the pieces of the puzzle a
puzzle that had managed to fool so many
but what I found was a story that left
people broken it felt like everything I
worked up to this point in my life has
been swept away and my biggest fear that
this is not over some people think this
Story begins and ends with Sam Bachmann
freed but that's wrong it is doomed to
repeat itself
[Music]
thank you
first for the last three years I've been
using notion on a daily basis who are
also the sponsors for today's video
notion essentially gives you a place to
store your notes your to-do lists your
goals and just about anything that's
inside of your head all in one place so
here is an example of a notion page
these pages are essentially like a blank
canvas where you can store whatever
information you like whether that is
just text tables or entire databases
with various properties this notion page
that you're looking at right now is
basically where I've organized
everything for the video that you are
watching right now on the right hand
side here you can see that I've created
a menu section that contains even more
pages within it this is an example of a
database that I've used to manage the
Motion Graphics for the video so you can
see that it allows me to keep track of
everything from what needs to be done to
delegate tasks out to motion graphic
designers and so on and so forth here
are some of the notes that we've taken
for meetings in the production of this
video and now with notion AI you can
literally summarize all of these into a
few key action points for ease of use if
I need to come back to this so here is
an example of a creative brief that I've
created for this video and then with
just the click of a button I can share
this page with other notion users to
collaborate with me on it or I can just
create a link to the page so that anyone
can access it even if they don't have
notion I can even use notion AI to help
Kickstart creative idea sessions so for
example generating title ideas for this
video and because you can get notion on
your phone you basically have all of
this all in one place wherever you go
it's insanely helpful you can get
started with notion for free today and
notion AI is only 10 a month using the
link in the description below these
videos take a lot of time and a lot of
money to create but it's thanks to you
guys and sponsors like notion and
literally notion as a software that I'm
able to continue creating them
[Music]
thank you
people want to make money and they want
to make it fast it can be out of greed
it can be out of desperation but if you
tell someone that there is a box that
they can put their money into and that
box will return back tenfold what you
gave it
how could you not be tempted from the
years of 2020 to 2021 the world of
cryptocurrencies had become that box for
regular people what is bitcoin what is
up with Bitcoin people are getting rich
from it everyone's chasing it Bitcoin is
going up forever Deirdre the mentality
was simple you think of crypto you think
of getting rich he became a millionaire
at 24 all by investing in Bitcoin I made
Millions with crypto you probably made
Millions as well we all knew someone
that never talked about investing before
and suddenly saying how they're putting
their money into crypto that it's the
future from a struggling music producer
from bankrupt to a millionaire it's a
millionaire this is basically winning
the lottery become the next crypto
millionaire even celebrities were
getting into it you have jumped into the
world of cryptocurrency I'm going to
Tweet out the information on how you can
buy this nft look at this and look like
they could be friends they're Buddies
the question really became how do I get
my piece of the pie
to understand the story that's about to
unfold I feel like the Super Bowl of
2022 is the best place to start not
because of the sports but because of the
ad breaks
an advert appears featuring Larry David
an actor who hasn't been in a commercial
ever the ad takes you through various
inventions in history the wheel toilets
coffee voting light bulbs at each stage
of a new invention it shows how many
critics dismissed and laughed at them
only to be proven wrong can I be honest
with you
it stinks however the real Twist of this
ad came at the end like I was saying
it's FTX it's a safe and easy way to get
into crypto and Larry responds yeah I
don't think so
and there it is big bold letters don't
miss out on crypto nfts the next best
thing and right next to it the logo
[Music]
if you wanted to buy crypto most regular
people would have to do it through a
cryptocurrency exchange think of it like
a central location that you deposit your
money into and from there you can place
orders to buy and sell cryptocurrencies
the exchange's job is to match you with
those buyers and sellers and once you've
made your riches you withdraw your money
from The Exchange into your bank account
they are the easiest gateways into the
world of crypto accessible from the very
phones in your pocket within the top
three cryptocurrency exchanges at the
time you had binance at number one owned
by a guy called Chiang pen Xiao nickname
CZ in second you had coinbase owned by a
man named Brian Armstrong and then
finally FTX I'm excited to be partnering
with FTX if you're wondering well what
is FTX FTX is like the best exchange
they're a safe exchange where people can
trade things like cryptocurrencies the
first crypto company to win naming
rights to a major US Arena FDX is a
platform where they offer 85 lower fees
than their top competitor they have the
most coins they have giveaways or they
give free coins FTX is the best crypto
Exchange in the world with no fixed fees
but this week I actually want to tell
you about Sam he's the young super
billionaire and founder of the FTX
Exchange
so we arrive at Sam bankman freed
nickname SBF
all right Sam tell us about yourself
yeah yeah my name is Sam bikeman freed
I'm
the yo co-founder of FTX did you ever
imagine that at 25 when you got involved
you would now be one of the most
important people in the crypto world and
have become a multi-billionaire no I
well no although not only one of the
nicest people in crypto but one of the
smartest as well SPF thanks for taking
the time out of your day down in the
Bahamas to join us how you doing over
there at only 30 years old this guy had
an estimated net worth of 26 billion
dollars I mean Forbes had already done
an article on him save for Mark
Zuckerberg no one in history has ever
gotten so rich so young Sam is a genius
an effective altruist and he's also the
wealthiest person under 30 in the world
his hair was disheveled his clothes
usually consisted of loose fitting
t-shirts and a pair of shorts you'd see
pictures of him sleeping on bean bags in
his office you trust the guy more when
you see the car he drives he's worth
like 20 billion dollars first of all his
appearance he's only 29 years old and he
typically wears a t-shirt or a
sweatshirt that has the FTX logo on it
khaki shorts very often when people get
wealthy they buy fancy suits and so
forth you haven't gone to that phase yet
right not too much it sounds a little
bit like most tech Bros I went to
college with not showering a ton a
really messy desk he was very much the
tech nerd genius stereotype
you searched him up online
pictures with him and celebrities like
Tom Brady with politicians like Bill
Clinton and Tony Blair then you find out
that FTX was founded in 2019. in other
words nobody knew who this guy was a few
years ago I spoke with Sam earlier this
month where he alluded to his plans to
give most of his fortune away Sam's
biggest Advantage was this image he had
built himself an image of a billionaire
dedicated to giving his wealth away
what's not to love about that the guy
you see next to me is the most generous
billionaire in the world do you have a
sense of how much of your fortune you'd
be willing to give away in the end I
mean in the end I think almost all of it
right like I'm not particularly excited
you know to to dive into luxury I'm not
excited about Yachts uh crypto
billionaire plans to give away 99 of his
money what about your own legacy Sam
what impact would you want to leave on
the world in the end my my goal is is to
do as much good as I can for the world
second proof I mean to the world that
this isn't that I really do
mean it
yeah
around May of 2022 a guy called Mark
cahodi's starts publicly broadcasting
his views about FTX and sandbagman freed
on Twitter
in the world of Finance kahodi's is what
you would call a short seller somebody
that bets against the success of a
company's stock and if they're right
they make money only a few months after
his initial tweets he had sent an email
to Bloomberg asking them to investigate
sambachman freed and FTX kahodis was
skeptical and one of his biggest
questions was related to Sam and his
background we just who was this guy
really and how did he achieve his status
in such a short period of time
[Music]
it was a fair question
foreign
to save the world don't get a job at a
charity go work on Wall Street that was
the title of a post on a forum in 2013
nine years before the Super Bowl of
2022. it was written by a guy called
William mccaskill he is the associate
professor of philosophy at the
University of Oxford co-founder of the
effective altruism movement for the last
10 years my colleagues and I have
developed a philosophy and research
program that we call effective optimism
he has pledged to donate everything you
earn to organizations he believes will
do the most good effect of altruism is a
philosophy and the community that's
about trying to figure out how can we do
as much good as possible with the time
and money we have what it boil down to
in its simplest form was figuring out
how to make the world a better place
using the most evidence-based approach
one strategy was known as earning to
give which meant maximizing your own
wealth so that you could give away more
to charitable causes or as others might
put it get filthy rich for Charity's
sake he described a student who had been
convinced by the philosophy and now
works in finance at a trading firm
called Jane Street giving away 50 of his
income to charitable causes in the same
year he made that Forum post mccaskill
heard of another student at MIT that may
be a good fit for the movement a 24 year
old physics undergraduate went by the
name Sam backman freed
and just like that sambachman freed was
introduced to effective altruism
it was a mathematics nerd with a passion
for utilitarianism and a vegan who
already engaged in animal rights
activism mccaskill persuaded sander
instead of working for charity directly
he could make a greater impact by
pursuing a high-paying career then
donate a substantial amount of his
income to charitable causes Sam was
convinced and just like the student
mentioned in mccaskill's Forum post Sam
decides to get a job at the same trading
firm known as Jane Street it was a
popular firm amongst other effective
altruists little did mccaskill realize
just how much damage his new convert
would cause the movement in the years to
come
[Music]
in the summer of 2021 sambangman freed
gets on a zoom call with partners of
Sequoia capital a venture capital firm
these were people who had invested in
apple Google Instagram and I could go on
the point is Sam was here to talk about
FTX in the hopes of convincing Sequoia
to invest money into the company he
tells them his vision for the exchange I
want FTX to be a place where you can do
anything you want with your next dollar
you can buy Bitcoin you can send money
in whatever currency to any friend
anywhere in the world you can buy a
banana they were impressed a few months
after that Zoom call they lead a round
of Investments for FTX which totaled
almost a billion dollars and a year
after that Zoom call two months before
the collapse Sequoia Capital releases
this 45-page article titled Sam banglund
freed has a savior complex and maybe you
should too in that article they reveal
that throughout the zoom call Sam had
been playing one of his favorite video
games League of Legends the article goes
on to talk about Sam's commitment to the
effect of altruism movement and when the
author sits down with him for an
interview he becomes convinced that Sam
is the real deal and may very well
become the world's first trillionaire
they even go as far as saying that
unlike other crypto companies FTX has a
unique selling point their ethical
Behavior
there's this image of who Sam was that
people were buying into an effective
altruist a crypto genius a nerd who
played video games whilst casually
pitching billion dollar investors
Sequoia wasn't some exceptional case you
know they were just one of the many big
institutional names investing into FTX I
mean we're talking temasek SoftBank
BlackRock Ontario teachers pension who
cares what the big boy institutions are
doing right I mean none of that means
anything to the average person remember
2021 was the year that everyone saw
crypto as this Fountain of wealth for
those that put their money into it to
reach these people FTX had to do one
thing
get in front of the things that they
cared about the Miami Heat arena famous
for hosting the Miami Heat NBA team well
in March of 2021 it became the FTX Arena
after signing a 19-year deal for 135
million dollars with FTX this year
they've been spending big bucks to get
mainstream name recognition TSM the
popular Esports organization most known
for their League of Legends team forget
that it's TSM FTX now thanks to a
10-year deal with FTX for 210 million
dollars FTX is putting their name
everywhere Tom Brady one of the greatest
quarterbacks in football history well
he's not only an ambassador for FTX now
he's also given equity in the company
and the same goes for the Brazilian
fashion model and Brady's wife at the
time Gisele Bundchen the entirety of
Major League Baseball well thanks to a
five-year partnership FTX were to become
the official cryptocurrency exchange of
the MLB every single umpire had the FTX
logo embroidered on their uniform
Formula One teams the international
cricket Council a baseball Superstar
Golden State Warriors you guys may have
seen their ads they're everywhere now
I'm not an expert and I don't need to
know and who could forget Kevin O'Leary
one of the Sharks on the popular show
Shark Tank had been rather critical of
the cryptocurrency space it is a useless
currency it is a useless currency to me
it's garbage become the crypto boom of
2021 and Kevin signs a 15 million dollar
deal with FTX to become an official
spokesperson for the exchange if there's
ever a place I could be that I'm not
going to get in trouble it's going to be
an FTX even some of the most popular
Finance influencers who generally gave
safe investment advice were taking on
sponsorship deals with FTX ftxus has
been a sponsor here on the channel for
the majority of the year I love FTX
among the cheapest fees out there check
out our sponsor ftxus a lot of these
influencers bought into Sam's image just
as much as actual institutional
investors did the real question was how
much of that image was real
or just a facade
foreign
[Music]
Street Sam decides to quit he had an
appetite for risk and by staying there
he felt like he could be missing out on
other opportunities one of his
colleagues at the time a 22 year old
named Caroline Ellison witnessed it
herself just like Sam she too was an
effective altruist with a love for
mathematics she thought it was unusual I
mean Sam was quitting his high-paying
job just because there may be other
opportunities out there of course
Caroline Ellison had no idea at the time
just how much her own career and
personal life would become entangled
with Sam's without a job Stan starts
writing a list of directions for his
life those things included becoming a
journalist venturing into politics
fundraising for a non-profit and
building a startup he would go on to
achieve almost all of those things but
before making a decision William
mccaskill offers him a job at the center
of effective altruism a company for the
EA movement to conduct various
activities and whilst there he befriends
another member of the movement a Woman
by the name of Tara McCauley who was
head of operations
that's when Sam started noticing
something
overall biggest winner today Bitcoin
rallied more than 10 today it's up 438
for 2017. the cryptocurrency has pushed
past seven thousand dollars you just
crossed the 16
000 threshold it is in the next 20 years
a million dollars a call at this point
Sam didn't have much of an interest in
cryptocurrencies but in 2017 the
cryptocurrency world was entering a
Mania although it was only a smaller
scale to the one that followed in 2021
it got on Sam's radar this is late 2017
when you know you walk down the streets
you hear two people talking you're like
that's probably about Bitcoin I mean I
don't know but you know pretty likely
more importantly Sam Bachman freed had
spotted something that others had not
and he needed to act fast in that same
year of 2017. Sam and his fellow
colleague Tara McCauley start a new
company together they call it
Alameda research see this this is it
right here everything everything that
was to come it all begins with Alameda
research
[Music]
when you look at the name alone Alameda
sounds like a research company in fact
that was intentional misdirection if you
named your company like we do
cryptocurrency Bitcoin Arbitrage no
one's going to give you a bank account
that's your company name but everyone
wants to serve a research institute
alameda's true purpose was to operate as
a cryptocurrency trade in firm in other
words they would be using their own
money to invest into crypto related
assets in order to make a profit but
like I mentioned Sam had noticed
something to purchase Bitcoin most
people used exchanges and the price of
Bitcoin generally remain the same across
all exchanges in the world with one
exception at the time some countries in
Asia had been selling Bitcoin for in
some cases five thousand dollars more
than what it was on other exchanges in
other words you're looking at five
thousand dollars profit per trade
sitting on the table it was practically
free money just one problem there were
far too many obstacles in the way
Capital controls Financial regulation
anti-money laundering laws and so on and
so forth most people couldn't work out
how to make the trade Sam however had a
card up his sleeve effective altruism
thanks to a Japanese member of the EA
Community Sam was able to skirt around
some of these obstacles Sam also secured
funding from wealthy effective altruist
members specifically a loan for 50
million dollars from yarn tarlin the
co-founder of Skype Alameda research
would first buy Bitcoin on a U.S
exchange then sell it at a higher price
on a Japanese exchange with the help of
their Japanese friend now the accounts
differ on how much this made Alameda
research some putting the figure at 10
million dollars others are 30 million
dollars either way
it was a success
but there's just one problem with
opportunities like this they don't last
forever once people start to catch on
the markets tend to adjust themselves
and it no longer becomes profitable by
January of 2018 Alameda could no longer
exploit the opportunity and then
something happened in April an event
that would be kept secret for a long
time an event that would rock the
foundations of Sam's first company an
event that would expose a side of his
character in the wood foreshadow much of
what was to come in
Sam bangman freed always wanted to get
into politics since leaving Jane Street
many years ago and in 2021 he had a
strong reason to follow that calling
Finance has kind of been in trouble in a
lot of countries in terms of regulatory
issues Finance the world's largest
cryptocurrency exchange and how it just
got banned in the United Kingdom Finance
has been banned from Ontario Canada not
authorized to operate in Japan either
throughout that year Regulators across
the world were setting their sights on
cryptocurrency exchanges more
specifically binance you know the most
popular cryptocurrency exchange at the
time owned by a guy called Chiang pen
Zhao the UK Japan Singapore Netherlands
and more were all warning finance that
they were not authorized to operate
within their countries Sam wanted to
make sure that FTX wouldn't go down that
same path how have you viewed what's
been happening with binance throughout
the world in recent months a week I
guess you know something else is that
you know we try really hard to be as
Cooperative as and
with Regulators then came a sign of Hope
in September of 2021 FTX was granted
regulatory approval in the Bahamas not
long after that Sam relocates the
headquarters of both FTX and Alameda
research to the city of Nassau Sam saw
the Bahamas as a country that could be
at the heart of this industry as Silicon
Valley for crypto you're right for the
presence of FDX
underscores the Readiness of the Bahamas
to be at home for global leaders in the
crypto space but that wasn't the only
place Sam had his eyes on throughout
2021 he was looking at another prize
Washington DC only months after moving
to the Bahamas Sam recruits a new member
into the FTX team a guy called Mark
Witcher wedgen was a former commissioner
for the cftc a regulatory agency in
charge of regulating derivative markets
in the U.S in other words he was Sam's
key to the doors of U.S politics and
regulation what followed was pretty
impressive only a month after hiring
wedge and Sam appeared in Congress to
testify for a hearing on digital assets
and the future of Finance the industry
has the potential to improve a lot of
people's lives and we're also happy to
talk with other Regulators about
potential products in the United States
right there in that room Sam was the
face of cryptocurrency Regulation I mean
rather than resist it he was embracing
it FTX went on to make regulatory wins
throughout 2021 we're talking Japan
Europe Africa Australia they had gone
down an entirely different path to
binance Sam went on to become the sixth
largest U.S political donor in the two
years leading up to the midterm
elections we're talking an estimated
number of 40 million dollars in
donations other FDX Executives had also
contributed I mean by the end of 2022
political donations associated with SPF
and FTX Executives exceeded 70 million
dollars
[Music]
same payment freed is the devil he is
the devil in crypto this guy's literally
trying to ruin crypto permanent and you
know what he says oh that's not what I'm
doing you liar you lie Sam Bateman free
bassam's political Ambitions they
started to rub people the wrong way one
of the bills that Sam had been
supporting was known as the dccpa ACT a
bill that would essentially make the
cftc the sole regulator of the crypto
industry but many in the crypto space
accused this bill of being destructive
to the cryptocurrency ecosystem the Sam
was trying to claim a monopoly on the
industry Sam Beckman freed was trying to
get some kind of legal Monopoly over the
crypto industry there was kind of this
like culture of Silence in crypto around
not opposing him opposing his views and
perhaps it exposed a side to Sam that
people hadn't seen before the part of
him that believed that the ends justify
the means or a desire for his crypto
Empire to come out on top no matter what
if people would know what had happened
at Alameda research in 2018 during that
month of April then perhaps everyone
might have seen it coming
foreign
co-founder of Alameda research Tara
McCauley was growing frustrated not just
her but many of the Alameda research
employees whilst their initial trades of
Bitcoin between the U.S and Japan had
been successful they were now losing
money and most of that blame was being
put on the other co-founder sambachmann
freed now was this growing concern over
Sam's alleged Reckless actions including
poor trading decisions being made by him
in a post made on the effective altruism
Forum an alleged employee describes how
he constantly displayed a flagrant
disregard for legal structures and
safeguards a belief that rules do not
apply to him an inclination to see the
ends justifying the means I mean the
picture that they painted of this guy
was not of a genius but of a young
inexperienced Reckless individual who
was harming the company with poor
management and trading decisions so Tara
along with other high-level employees
decide to confront Sam I mean they tell
him directly you have to leave the
company you Behavior can no longer be
tolerated that month of April would be
known internally as the April Fiasco
Sam's response
he refused to leave not long after that
Tara McCauley and close to half the
employees at Alameda many of whom were
effective altruists queer allegedly
those former employees raised concerns
to hire members in the effective
altruism Community warning of Sam's
Reckless Behavior and how he was a bad
representative for the movement those
allegations were supposedly ignored or
not taken seriously
this piece of the puzzle right here it's
the one that foreshadows everything but
by the time people would find out about
the April Fiasco it would already be too
late
with a large chunk of his employees gone
from Alameda research Sam had to
re-establish his team first you've got
Gary Wang I mean he joined Alameda
research from its Inception at only 24
years old Wang supposedly met Sam at a
math summer camp in 2008 he was very
much the technical brains of the
business nishad Singh Facebook employee
only five months before joining Alameda
research age 21 years old much like Wang
he helped with the technical
infrastructure at Alameda then you have
Caroline Ellison remember her the former
colleague of Sam's at Jane Street who
saw him quit turns out Sam managed to
convince her to leave that job she
joined Alameda research not long before
the April Fiasco as a Trader then we've
got Andy Krogan former employee to
another trading firm and now the Chief
Operating Officer of Alameda research he
was the adult in the room Krogan had
once told Sam to cut his hair to which
Sam replied I think it's important for
people to think I look crazy now when
you look at this team one thing sticks
out
they're very young with the trading firm
like Alameda research the more money
they have access to the more they can
trade and the more they can profit so
the Alameda team decides to put together
a pitch deck a presentation that's
designed to attract potential investors
to invest their funds with Alameda I
mean it was filled with all sorts of
insane claims we're the best crypto
trading firm in the United States we
haven't had a losing week in six months
they boasted high returns of 15 with no
risk these loans have no downside I mean
to to claim no risk and to say that they
hadn't had a losing week which seems to
go against all accounts of what happened
during the April Fiasco it felt as
though Alameda was desperate for money
it's unlikely that this pitch deck was
successful but I guess that didn't
matter because Sam had been working on a
secret project so uh you got involved
because you thought it would be in a
creative new area to get involved with I
always want certain exchange because it
just seemed like really important
products in the crypto ecosystem that
were worth a lot you see crypto
exchangers make their money by charging
a fee for every trade a person makes on
their platform right so in other words
they make money regardless of whether
the person making the trade is losing
money in May of 2019 Sam launches a
brand new cryptocurrency exchange FTX he
would be the majority owner whilst Gary
Wang who helped build the infrastructure
for it would own 10 Sam now owned both a
cryptocurrency exchange and a
cryptocurrency trading firm see there's
something already bizarre about this all
and not just the fact that these
companies are being run by Young and
arguably inexperienced people but also
the conflict of interest Sam owning an
exchange is fine whatever but owning his
own trading firm Alameda research which
uses FTX as a platform you see that
opens up a gaping hole for example how
exactly does FTX ensure that no special
privileges are given to Alameda
yeah
the Super Bowl of February 2022 was this
defining moment for the crypto space I
mean some even called it the crypto Bowl
because of how many crypto related
companies were advertising during the
event these companies had grown
incredibly Rich over the last few years
riding the waves of new investors from
both institutions and regular people all
handing over their cash definitely been
an exciting year across crypto Bitcoin
has a great track to 100K by the year
end the bright orange future that is
Bitcoin
when you're riding high on the good
times everyone and their mother was like
yeah Bitcoin to 100K to a million to 10
million in 10 years the notion that the
music building for the last few years
could stop I had everything in a group
and against my better judgment I didn't
cash out seems impossible I'm not an
expert and I don't need to be
like I was saying it's FTX it's a safe
and easy way to get into crypto until
yeah I don't think so until it does
[Music]
FDX already started off successful I
mean thanks to Alameda research they
were able to provide volume to The
Exchange right from the Jump by July
2019 SPF was already in talks with
investors by August that same year they
managed to raise 8 million dollars not
only were they getting investments from
Venture Capital firms they were also
raising money from their competition you
remember binance right the top crypto
exchange owned by a guy called CZ well
in December of that year finance invests
an undisclosed amount into FDX also
taking an equity ownership in the
company it sparked what seemed to be a
friendly relationship between CZ and SBF
little did Sam realize that the very man
who invested that money into his company
would deal the final blow to his Empire
years later but perhaps one of their
smartest moves was the creation of ftt a
piece of the puzzle that would become
instrumental in the years to come see in
the world of cryptocurrencies anyone can
start their own coin I mean all they are
is programmable money put on a database
or as others might put it magical
internet money from nothing that has no
real value other than what people
speculate as value to be on July 29 2019
FTX launches their token coin called ftt
with a total supply of 350 million most
of which was owned by Alameda and FTX
the launch was a success I mean by
August the price of FDT Rose to 1.81
cents which made FTX and Alameda supply
of FDT tokens worth millions of dollars
just like that
magical internet money right but that's
not the real stroke of Genius here you
see the truth is since they were the
majority holders of the token they could
never really sell all of it I mean the
price of the tokens would completely
crash if they tried to do that no but
what they could do was point to their
ftt tokens that are valued in the
millions of dollars and use it as
collateral to take out loans or to
Simply say oh look how much we have in
assets even though part of that is
really just ftt tokens whose value is
mostly tied to speculation it's almost
insane to think about
but it worked
story of the week was the collapse of
Terra Luna it was a rough rough week for
crypto investors does Tara Luna just
crash in five days from ninety dollars
99 down to 72 Cents Only months after
the Super Bowl of 2022 a catastrophe in
the cryptocurrency space was unfolded
Tara and Luna were two cryptocurrencies
that had just crashed in value wiping
out an estimated 60 billion dollars in
the crypto space I don't think there's
ever been a crypto event a bad event
this large in crypto history Luna to
book all my monies what was
115 Grand
about a month ago was now
about two dollars man the collapse of
Terror and Luna was like suddenly you go
from relaxing to being jolted awake on
high alert because everyone is looking
around and they're all asking who will
be the most affected by this who will be
next
after the terror and lunar
cryptocurrencies collapsed The Dominoes
began to fall bit by bit crypto hedge
fund three arrows Capital ordered by
Court to liquidate it had exposure to
the now collapsed Terror USD stable coin
everyone is intertwined in some way more
pain in the world of crypto Voyager
digital files for chapter 11 bankruptcy
protection should I left my money in
Voyager with all my life savings in the
bid a major crypto lender went from
managing billions in assets to filing
for bankruptcy I did just get by
Celsius last week this is the third
major crypto company to file for
bankruptcy coinbase is laying off
workers along with blockfi and
crypto.com what is going on throughout
all of this FTX and sandbagman freed
were not only doing fine they were
doubling down on the industry I mean in
fact Sam was trying to rescue some of
the companies that were going bankrupt
by either giving them a line of credit
or just straight up buying them out
crypto world is now gonna get a bailout
Sam bankman free CEO of crypto exchange
FTX is keeping the industry as prices
take a hit he's keeping them stable
today it was announced that Sam bigman
freed up FTX was going to buy Voyager
for roughly 1.4 billion dollars Sam's
Empire wasn't shrinking amongst the
chaos it was growing he was being
pitched as this savior I mean you had
people coming out and calling him the JP
Morgan of the cryptocurrency industry
you bailed out some companies yeah uh
what money did you use to do that do you
still have enough cash if you needed to
do another bailout
yeah they call them the JP Morgan
of crypto there's a relatively
understated life for a billionaire he
drives a Toyota Corolla to ftx's offices
in the Bahamas he lives with 10
roommates and a golden doodle named
gopher they want you to focus on this
weirdo who sleeps on the beach in a
commune all shucksy has CNBC down and
not look at what's really going on
whether it's money laundering or crime
or covering a job or what's really going
on behind the scenes
investors believed in Sam or at least
the very idea of him allegedly Andy
Krogan would make sure that investors
visiting the headquarters would be able
to see Sam sleeping on a beanbag and
then have him wake up and enter the
meetings usually wearing shorts it was
intentional Sam knew that more powerful
than just a balance sheet is a story by
early 2022 FTX had raised billions of
dollars from investors and was valued at
32 billion dollars not a single one of
ftx's big name investors sat on the
board of directors to oversee Sam's
operations which was usually common
practice investors would report that Sam
wanted to run his company with little
oversight and if anyone was interested
in investing they should support that
decision take it or leave it in July of
2021 Sam solidified his ownership over
his Empire when he decided to buy back
chang Peng Xiao the founder of binance's
stake in his company for a sizeable
chunk of ftt tokens in return
sambachmann freed was the reigning owner
of his Empire with his Focus primarily
on FTX Alameda research was being run by
two individuals Caroline Ellison was the
first who we already know of but in 2019
Sam hires a 27 year old named Sam
trabucca to join Alameda as a Trader
alongside Caroline Ellison Trabuco first
met SBF at a maths camp in 2010 and then
two years later reconnected at MIT there
were some pretty bizarre tweets made by
Trabuco in 2021 at one tweet detailed
alameda's strategy of holding a position
in Dogecoin a cryptocurrency created
from a meme based on tweets by Elon Musk
and in that same tweet thread Trabuco
brags about their ability Alameda to
make good bets I mean it paints this
picture of Alameda research one that
doesn't seem like a place with
sophisticated individuals making
calculated trades based on proper risk
assessment yeah absolutely could pull it
off without my math degree I used very
little math use a lot of like Elementary
School math some Bang
in October of 2021
I know what you're thinking I mean of
all the pieces of the puzzle so far how
could things possibly go wrong from here
but you're not paying attention all the
pieces
they are there
leading up to November 2022 something
started happening in August Sam Trabuco
the co-ceo of Alameda research with
Caroline Ellison resigns from his
position stating that he's chosen to
prioritize other things a month later
Brit Harrison president for the U.S
subsidiary of FTX resigns from his
position then a month after that an
article comes out from the Block saying
that Jonathan Cheesman head of
over-the-counter and institutional sales
left FDX last month as well something
was up Sam bankman freed had managed to
build himself this Empire in only a few
years but the throne that he was sitting
on was made of glass and then it finally
arrived
the coindesk rapport
foreign
cryptocurrency publication releases an
article titled divisions in sambachman
Freed's crypto Empire blur on his
trading Titan alameda's balance sheet
someone had leaked Alameda researchers
balance sheet and coindesk had managed
to get their hands on it see a balance
sheet can tell you a lot about the
health of the company namely how much
money they have access to and how much
money they owe that coindesk report
outlines that there are two divisions to
sandbachman Freed's Empire FTX his
crypto exchange and Alameda research his
crypto trading firm but this we already
knew even though these two divisions
were supposed to be completely separate
from one another coindesk stated that
those divisions become a little bit
blurry when you look at Alameda
research's balance sheet out of the 14.6
billion dollars of assets shown on
Alameda researchers balance sheet a
large portion of those assets with the
ftt token in other words the majority of
Alameda researchers Equity was coming
from an illiquid crypto token created by
their own sister company that report
confirmed the fears that FTX and Alameda
are closer linked than previously
imagined or followed would be a week of
disaster
the founder of binance tweets to his
millions of followers that he plans to
sell all of the FDT tokens that binance
holds If You Remember Violence had
received a batch of FDT tokens when Sam
backman freed repurchased binance's
shares in FTX a year prior with that
single tweet alone
hit the fan my dad says it will
liquidate its entire position in the FTX
token Finance CEO disclosed plans to
exit the ftt positions as part of risk
management strategy per tweets shared
over the weekend are you scared are you
worried that your bags are gonna go to
zero Finance selling their chunk of FDT
would mean driving down the value of
those tokens in the process but perhaps
even worse was the Panic that that tweet
caused or anyone else could see from the
outside was that binance the top crypto
exchange didn't believe in FTX anymore
why
a few hours later Caroline Ellison makes
a tweet she asks if CZ would be willing
to sell his FDT tokens directly to
Alameda research for 22 in other words
preventing a massive crash in the price
of ftt of course that would be an
Alameda research's benefit given that
most of their assets were literally made
up of FDT tokens
easy basically refuses tweeting that we
won't pretend to make love after divorce
and that we won't Supply people who
Lobby against other industry players
behind their backs what you're looking
at is a showdown between two of the
biggest cryptocurrency exchanges all
happening on Twitter whilst this is
going on the value of FDT tokens has
been dropping rapidly panic and fear in
situations like this are lethal if you
know CZ you know he never sells anything
he has a policy of long-term holding and
this the way he framed it made it sound
like something was truly wrong with
Alameda Finance is selling it Sally at
all okay they're not even trying to hide
it you see the news about Alameda it
wasn't just a reflection on Alameda it
was a reflection on Samberg and freed
and FTX as well I mean think about it if
you had your money deposited in FTX all
your life savings and you find out that
its sister company is facing troubles
and that another Titan of the industry
from an even bigger exchange doesn't
want anything to do with FTX what would
you do well you probably want to get
your money out of there all of a sudden
massive massive massive outflows from
FTX all of a sudden everyone starts
getting scared in banking there's this
concept known as a bank run if people
start to lose their confidence in a bank
for whatever reason customers are likely
to start withdrawing money from their
accounts however if the bank doesn't
have enough money in its reserves to
fulfill all of those withdrawals It
ultimately collapses crypto exchanges
sort of operate like Banks you deposit
your money into them and for the most
part your money stays in that
exchanger's account until you eventually
withdraw right now with FTX anyone who
doesn't want to withdraw will look at
everyone else and go well I didn't want
to withdraw but I also don't want to be
the victim of a bankron so I kind of
have to as you can imagine it's a pretty
deadly cycle and nothing fuels it better
than panic and confusion
as the withdrawal requests on FTX start
piling up Sam puts out a tweet saying
that FTX is fine there's nothing to be
worried about they have enough money to
cover all their customers deposits and
then there's silence
[Music]
it's easy he's now tweeting that FTX has
asked for his help he's saying that they
were facing a liquidity crunch but he
signed a non-binding letter of intent to
buy out his Rivals company and save them
from their time of distress the biggest
story in all of crypto land to exchange
binance announced a deal to buy rival
ftx.com probably the most dramatic deal
I've ever seen in the history of the
crypto industry for a moment there was
hope this is a Chokehold this is
fighting your competitor and telling
your competitor actually asks for your
home this has uh been one hell of a
roller coaster if FTX was facing a
liquidity crunch it simply meant that
FTX has the money to support withdrawals
it just isn't able to get to that money
fast enough it's an issue that's
solvable Elise that's what we all
thought
only a day after CZ announces his
potential buyout Bloomberg and the Wall
Street Journal both publish articles
stating that for months the SEC and the
cfdc both U.S regulatory agents in
charge of Securities have been
investigating FTX specifically whether
FDX has been mishandling customer funds
now hold on up to this point the biggest
concern was FDX having a liquidity
crunch being unable to fulfill on
customer withdrawal requests these
investigations though they were
suggesting something much more sinister
Finance as a result of corporate due
diligence as well as the latest news
reports regarding mishandled customer
funds we have decided that we will not
pursue the potential acquisition of
ftx.com Finance the largest crypto
Exchange in the world is highly unlikely
to go through with its proposed
acquisition of struggling rival FTX
after less than a day what just happened
it was happening and suddenly now it's
not Finance said quote Our Hope was to
be able to support ftx's customers that
the issues are beyond our control or
ability to help
basically I couldn't believe it like
you're you're I was in complete
disbelief this isn't happening no this
isn't real this isn't real and that was
it
the death sentence
Sam comes out with a Twitter thread
saying that he's sorry in that thread he
said that he's going to do right by the
users that he's doing everything he can
to raise liquidity that they're in talks
with a number of players
tonight the cryptocurrency world is
really just moments ago FTX filed for
bankruptcy from a 32 billion dollar
company to bankruptcy in the matter of
just four days or so there's so much we
don't know there's so much we don't know
well here's what we know he's broke and
he's in big trouble he's in big trouble
up to this point
nobody truly knew how did one of the
largest crypto exchanges run by a man
who was only a month ago seen as this
savior to the crypto space within a week
suddenly filed for bankruptcy there was
a sense of what the hell just happened
whatever had gone wrong whatever Sam had
been hiding throughout all of these
years it was time for it all to come to
light
just a few days after declaring
bankruptcy Sam begins his now Infamous
tweet thread which just began
cryptically as one what over the next
few hours he starts tweeting a string of
letters eventually forming the words
happened I don't even know what is going
on here I mean the incompetency here is
absolutely mind-boggling here from SBI
like who does this like why would you do
this what what is he trying to get
attention is he just like toying with us
I saw what Sam was doing it was like
adding insult the injury then came the
media reports about how FTX may have
been taking customer deposits and
loaning them out to their sister company
Alameda research some figures citing 10
billion dollars worth of loans now you
have a situation where not only has the
fall been so sudden but there are
accusations of seriously fraudulent
Behavior you're not gonna believe this
between one billion and 2 billion of FTX
customer funds disappear it's been one
of the most depressing one of the most
difficult 48
56 hours of my life FTX what is going on
here right there's a lot of alarm bells
ringing there's not a lot of answers
that are currently circulating there's
this Rising feeling of panic and
confusion and anger people were
basically picking up their pitchforks
and going who is responsible for this
and of course some of the first people
to feel that anger were the former
promoters of FTX I can't trust anybody
now that had any
very pissed off at these YouTube
fluffers who have been promoting FTX
over the past year or so all paid
eye-watering amounts of money to promote
to this garbage I can't even begin to
share how devastated and sorry I am
A-list celebrities plus Kevin O'Leary
told you what a great firm it was I
don't think that guy has an evil bone in
his body Kevin O'Leary Mr Wonderful is
going around and in a Despicable way
he's still standing up for Sam bankman
free you can love him or hate him given
what's happened but he was one of the
most brilliant Traders
in the crypto Universe Tom Brady Gisele
Bundchen Larry David Naomi Osaka and
Steph Curry are among the celebrities
accused in a class action lawsuit class
action lawsuit alleged that the crypto
platform FTX misled customers leading to
billions of dollars in lawsuit if you
had money there if you trusted them if
you played by the rules your money's
gone people wanted answers how could
this have happened how didn't anyone see
this happening most importantly
what just happened then came the
bankruptcy filings from John Ray
never in my career have I seen a
complete failure of corporate controls
and such a complete absence of
trustworthy financial information has
occurred here those were the infamous
words from John Ray the new CEO of FDX
whose job it was to preside over the
bankruptcy proceedings John Ray was the
same person who oversaw the bankruptcy
of Enron one of the largest cases of
corporate fraud in American history in
the FTX filings John Ray paints this
picture that starts to look really
daunting I mean first have a look at
this this right here is just a taste of
how convoluted and complex Sam backman
Freed's Empire really was every single
box you see is a company all of which
fit under a particular silos of the
Empire including Alameda research and
FTX all of which have their majority
ownership tracing back to Sam bankman
freed John Ray outlines how the empire
fell under hands of a very small group
of inexperienced unsophisticated and
potentially compromised individuals I
mean the stuff that came out from those
filings just became
more and more insane SBF had supposedly
been using applications to communicate
which was set to Auto delete after a
short period of time encouraging other
employees to do the same they had been
using software to conceal the misuse of
customer funds one part in particular
mentioned how Alameda research was
specifically given an exemption from the
Auto Liquidation protocol which is a
mechanism designed to stop customers on
FTX from borrowing more money than they
should be from the exchange it reveals
some absolutely mind-boggling things
including amongst others the fact that
FTX didn't even have an accountant as
all of this is going on I think most
people expected Sam to go on the run
right or or just to stay silent anything
that wasn't what he actually did the
first big announcement came from the New
York Times They were hosting an event
with some well-known speakers and among
those speakers was none other than Sam
Bachmann freed the shock to everyone was
threefold I mean first that Sam is still
active and staying in the Bahamas
seemingly facing no consequences for
what's happening second that the New
York Times is platforming what may be
the biggest Financial criminal of the
last decade and third that he isn't
running he's doing a damn media tour Sam
bankman free joins us right now live
from the Bahamas I didn't ever uh try to
commit fraud on anyone I I was excited
about the prospects of FTX a month ago
was there co-mingling of funds that's
what it appears like it appears like
there's a genuine commingling of the
funds that are of FTX customers that
were not supposed to be commingled with
your separate firm
I ain't knowing leeco mingle funds some
admitted that mistakes were made but
pretty much denied any sort of
fraudulent Behavior the first Network
interview with Sam bankman freed the
founder of the cryptocurrency exchange
FTX so you do know and you did know that
FDX deposits were being funneled to
Alameda so I was vaguely aware that that
was how some wires were being sent in
the first place
um didn't that set off alarm bells in
your head look I really deeply wish that
I had taken like a lot more
responsibility for understanding
what the details were of what was going
on there here's what Mark Cuban has to
say about that yep he said if I were him
I'd be afraid of going to jail for a
long time then when our stories coming
out about FTX and its senior Executives
including Sam Bachman Freed's very own
family spending up to 300 million
dollars on property in the Bahamas other
stories about how most of Sam's inner
circular FTX and Alameda were living in
the same luxury Penthouse apartment in
the Bahamas rumors and allegations that
all 10 had been involved in romantic
relationships with each other old tweets
of Caroline Ellison were brought to the
surface of her use of amphetamines at
the picture that was being painted was
of young inexperienced and Reckless
Executives running a company responsible
for billions of dollars some described
it as a operation ran by a gang of kids
in the Bahamas
while Sam had all the Limelight it
wasn't quite clear what was going on
with other players in the story Caroline
Ellison had been missing and some people
reportedly spotted her in AIDS Starbucks
Gary Wang also became a topic for
conversation namely who the hell was
this guy where did he come from because
there was barely any information about
him out there and his partner is a guy
named Gary Wang
and no one can find on Gary Wang
and the only thing you can really find
on Gary Wang on the Internet is one
picture and a picture of his back facing
a computer where he was a advisor to
Sequoia I think Sam was convinced that
if he continued speaking if he could
keep telling people that his goal was to
make customers whole
that he would be fine you're certain
that it's once the dust is settled and
once all the investigations have
happened that you won't be
arrested for fraud I don't think I will
be I don't think that I I I don't think
I tried to do anything wrong
um the once Crown King of crypto now
adorned in handcuffs former billionaire
FDX founder Sam bankman freed arrested
in the Bahamas today on the 12th of
December Sam mcmen freed was eventually
arrested in the Bahamas at the behest of
the United States very shortly after
that both the SEC and the cftc file
complaints against sandbachman freed and
FTX those documents
they alleged even worse allegations
bangman freed raised more than 1.8
billion dollars from investors
unbeknownst to those investors bangman
freed was orchestrating a massive
years-long fraud diverting billions of
dollars of the trading platform's
customer funds for his own personal
benefit and to help grow his crypto
Empire it just got progressively worse
these documents allege that from the
very beginning of ftx's creation FTX
would take the money their customers
deposited into their accounts and
provide Alameda research unlimited
access to them those funds would then be
used to make speculative Investments pay
for lavish real estate and even large
political donations then when the crypto
Market started crashing in 2022 Alameda
research couldn't pay back the loans
that were now being demanded from them
so FTX and the orders of sambachman
freed directed billions more of
customers assets to Alameda research to
pay those loans quote there was no
meaningful distinction between FTX
customer funds and Alan meet his own
funds we're now just recapping the news
that just broke the SEC filing charges
against Sam bankman freed unbeknownst to
those investors Sam Beckman free was
orchestrating a massive years-long fraud
diverting billions of dollars the cftc
has now sued Sam bank and freed for
violations of federal Commodities laws
there are also claims that those
Executives took hundreds of millions of
dollars in loans from Alameda and used
it to buy stuff like real estate over
the years trusting customers had been
putting their money into FDX accounts
unbelanced to them their money would be
taken and used for whatever means Sam
backman freed saw fit I was following
the situation quite well after all of
this and I was horrified how did this go
up
for so long how can I do this kind of
these kinds of things without no
oversight this morning we unsealed an
eight count indictment charging Samuel
bankman freed ftx's founder
with a series of interrelated fraud
schemes that contributed to ftx's
collapse well tonight he's in jail in
the Bahamas facing U.S charges and what
a federal prosecutor calls one of the
biggest Financial frauds in American
history those charges included
committing and conspiracy to commit wire
fraud on customers and lenders
Securities fraud money laundering and
violation of campaign Finance laws a
total of eight criminal charges based on
that information alone Sam was looking
at 115 years in prison the southern
district of New York has filed charges
against Caroline Ellison the former CEO
of Alameda research and Gary Wong a
co-founder of FTX in connection with
their roles in the frauds that
contributed to ftx's collapse both Miss
Ellison and Mr Wong have pled guilty to
those charges the once Inner Circle
members of sambang and Freed's Empire
had now turned against him from his jail
cell in the Bahamas Sam Bachman freed
would agree to be extradited back to the
United States where he pled no not
guilty to the charges levied against him
setting himself up for a trial in
October of 2023. in the meantime Sam
bankman freed remains on house arrest at
his parents home in California only a
month ago this was a man who was at the
height of his Fame and reputation that
was all shattered in a matter of weeks
FTX had exposed a resounding failure on
so many fronts and ultimately the price
was paid not by Sam bangman freed but by
the real victims in this story it's easy
to throw around headlines with big
million dollar figures of losses
but the real losses came from those who
didn't have millions to lose it felt
like everything I worked up to this
point in my life has been just like
there were different memories flashing
in my head of all the races you get that
were approve all the money you get
Christmas bonuses it would be all the
same if I just took those checks and
burned them and thrown them into the
wind or whatever what would you say to
if you if you could speak to him if I
could appeal to his Humanity if there's
any left just ask him to make it to make
it right and you can't even imagine
what this did to people that are way
less fortunate than you and how it
really destroyed lives
I wish I could say that this story ends
here
but I don't think that's the case
arguably one of the biggest catalysts
for ftx's collapse began with Chiang pen
Xiao otherwise known as CZ the owner of
the largest cryptocurrency Exchange in
the world finance
Finance throughout its years has
struggled with regulators and plagued
with allegations of allowing money
laundering through its platform a
hackers group called Lazarus which funds
the North Korean weapons program Hydra
which is a dark net drug dealing Network
Grand effects which is run by organized
criminals the thing they have all got in
common is they used a crypto exchange
platform called binance Finance just
like FDX has their own token called BNB
and just like FTX binance are the
majority holders of that coin Chiang
Peng Zhao in addition to being the
majority owner of binance is associated
with two other crypto trading firms much
like Alameda research one of which has
been reported to have received around
400 million dollars from the U.S Finance
exchange now it's unclear whether that
money came from customer funds or not
and binance has said that these findings
are outdated but without any further
elaboration after the events of FTX
binance releases a proof of Reserve
ordered from a third party in an attempt
to Showcase their transparency and prove
that all customer assets on the platform
are fully backed that report has since
been taken down by the firm who
performed the order citing concerns over
the way these reports are understood by
the public and that they have
limitations when providing assurances to
customers this is this is a little bit
of a red flag for me while they would
pull this Finance has some weird stuff
going on right now they essentially said
that the audit only covered what binance
wanted them to see to this day CZ has
not clearly specified where binance is
headquartered some big moves in the
crypto space this hour the cftc suing
the world's top exchange binance and its
founder CZ over several years we've
found that binance has been evading U.S
law their lawsuit Begins by identifying
binance as an exchange quote emerging
through an opaque web of corporate
entities the binance has acted with
intentional disregard for federal law
including laws designed to prevent and
detect money laundering and Terror and
financing is ban in the UK is under
investigation by U.S justice department
for money laundering 8 billion dollar
money from Iran the regulator should be
thinking carefully that's a walking time
bomb
you want to know the worst part about
the FTX story
it's that I don't think it's the last